a universal newsreel of 1960 a state of
the union address by president dwight
eisenhower this was eisenhower's last
year of his second term in office
eisenhower gives the congress his annual
state of the union message predicting a
boom in the economy revealing
spectacular advances in development of
the atlas missile and reviewing the
prospects for peace
first i point out that for us
annual self-examination is made a
necessity
by the fact that we live in a divided
world of uneasy equilibrium
with our side committed to its own
protection and against
aggression
by the other
with both sections of this divided world
in possession of unbelievably
destructive weapons
mankind approaches a state where mutual
annihilation becomes a possibility
no other fact of today's world equals
this in importance
it covers everything we say
everything we plan and everything we do
there is demanded of us vigilance
determination
and the dedication
of whatever portion of our resources may
be needed to provide adequate security
especially to provide a real deterrent
to aggression
these things we are doing
and these facts emphasize the importance
of striving incessantly for a just peace
only through the strengthening of the
spiritual
intellectual
economic and defensive resources of the
free world
can we in confidence
make progress toward this goal
[Applause]
[Music]